if you didn't know what you believe
about the world and how it works
causes you to make decisions those
decisions affect your life no kidding
huh
we kind of know that so what you believe
about the world about money and about
the economics matters because it either
paralyzes you like a deer in the
headlights or it causes you to push
forward persevere fight and climb and
scratch because you believe you control
your own destiny these things matter
these discussions of philosophy and
theology matter because they affect
whether or not you actually take the
advice I give you every single day on
the show and go use it so when someone
comes against that I occasionally want
to just stop and go let's apply a little
critical thought to this so let me ask
you this here's a here's a belief that
you have and I want you to call in
because we're going to talk about this
the entire hour get ready it's going to
be juicy yeah what causes poor people to
be poor what do you believe about that
because what you believe about that will
cause you to take actions in your own
life or not take actions in your own
life what causes poor people to be poor
it's a great question it'll challenge
your theology it will challenge your
doctrine it will challenge challenge
your philosophy of life because the
first thing that happens is if you have
a fairly narrow view of life meaning you
haven't gotten out much or don't read
much you have just one opinion and it's
usually wrong because it's only a
partial observation let me give you an
example that okay this article was just
published in the Washington Post the
headline reads Christians are more than
twice as likely to blame a person's
poverty on lack of effort
more than twice as likely to blame a
person's poverty on lack of effort
Washington Post and Kaiser Family
Foundation asks 16 hundred and
eighty-six American adults to answer the
question what causes poverty and I'm not
going to go through the whole article
but I'll pull out the statistics for you
because they bounce around and do some
weird theological stuff that's not even
cream know how to end up in the article
it's like dealing with post
millennialism and all this other stuff
that has nothing to do with the
discussion if they really got convoluted
but the bottom line of the article is
this the poll shows that 46% of all
Christians said that a lack of effort is
generally to blame for a person's
poverty compared with 29 percent of all
non-christians now what you believe
about this affects your behaviors let me
show you how it takes your behaviors The
Washington Post is well renowned for
being anti-christian and being very
liberal and their conservative beliefs
okay you don't believe that you read the
post all right it's pretty simple so let
me help you with this 46% of all
Christians said that a lack of effort is
generally to blame for a person's
poverty compared with 29 percent of all
non-christians so let me show you how
your belief affects your behavior the
headline was Christians are more more
than twice as likely to blame a person's
property on lack of effort let me help
you with this twenty nine percent forty
six percent that is not more than twice
it's not even half so you messed up your
math because of your skewed bias on your
belief system see how it affects your
behaviors you could have that if it were
written by the right-wing they all right
it could have said the exact same
statistics could have said less than
half of Christians believe less than
half
Christian's blame a person's poverty on
lack of ever because it's 46 percent
believe that according to this survey
you see how how it gets skewed how they
reword stuff to make a point cuz they
obviously have a point 53 percent of
white evangelical protestant protestants
blamed a lack of effort while 41 percent
blame circumstances 50 percent of
catholics blamed lack of effort on
poverty while 45 percent blame
circumstances in contrast by more than
two to one the bright people in america
the atheists the agnostics who have no
particular affiliation said
circumstances are more to blame when a
person is poor rather than a lack of
effort 65 percent of them said the
circumstances only 31 percent said a
lack of effort now listen to this line
this is fabulous if you don't think that
our media on both sides of the equation
right and left are completely screwed in
the head this will tell you right here
the question is of course not just an
ethical one ethical if they got a
dictionary in that place ethical is this
an ethical question but it's a political
one and the partisan divide is sharp
well no kidding that's why you wrote the
article among democrats 26 percent
blamed a lack of effort 72% said
circumstances liberals among republicans
63 percent blamed a lack of effort and
32 percent blamed circumstances
conservatives and race mattered to 32
percent of black christians blamed lack
of effort compared to 64 percent who
blamed circumstances so if you are a
white evangelical christian you hate the
poor you are cold-hearted unethical you
do nothing but sit in your McMansion
with your nose in the air collecting
your unequal wealth you're greedy and
you can't be trusted
to walk around on the face of the planet
because you blame effort on poverty
poverty on effort or lack of effort now
you want to talk about this this is
going to be a great discussion today the
phone numbers triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 see
the implication of this is only the
liberal elite only people with skinny
jeans and
really cool beards that let that have an
I love Bernie 2016 and a coexist bumper
sticker on their Subaru I have the right
to properly assess the poor now let me
help you with this if you are in skinny
jeans and you have a really cool beard
and you drive a Subaru with a coexist
sticker I'm your friend I'll be your
friend
I am your polar opposite but I will be
your friend I Drive a large pickup that
will eat your Prius um 6.0 I carry a
1911 with a hollow point in the chamber
wilson combat night on my yep most days
99% of time you see me I'm armed I
almost always vote conservative I hate
the government intervention in my life
so I'm the opposite of you and I am a
white evangelical I am the devil
incarnate which automatically means I'm
racist although I'm not half of the
Ramzi personalities are black if you
hadn't noticed and some of my best
friends on the planet by the way oh it
must be sexist too up you got a problem
there half the ramsey personalities are
women hmm see this is a hateful premise
is what it is and the Conservatives are
not right on this issue and the Liberals
are not right on this issue but to write
trash like this in a major newspaper is
not only unfair and divisive it's also a
lie it's untrue and I'm going to give
you some data and walk you through this
to show you what I'm talking about not
to defend the white evangelical
Christian but to discuss our worldview
of what causes someone to be poor
so the washington post poll and article
says 46% of all Christians said a lack
of effort is generally to blame for a
person's poverty compared with 29% of
all Christians and that includes
Catholics Protestants and they give the
different breakdowns I covered that in
the first segment so here's the problem
this is a hateful premise and we have to
stop dividing everyone down these lines
of liberal conservative black white this
polarizations got to stop if you are
driving a Subaru with a coexist sticker
on it I'll be your friend I'm not mad at
you I don't have to go along with your
political beliefs or ideologies to like
you or to be your friend or help you if
you call in if you need some help with
your money I'll help you I'll show you
how to fix it I'm I'll help you and I
don't agree on anything politically or
religiously or whatever that's fine
that's cool I mean I when I go to
Atlanta the guy that I've used for 10
years the drives a car for me down there
he owns a car service is a wonderful
guy's name's Elijah he owns about 10
cars and desert has a big car service I
help him and talk to him about business
and he's Muslim and he in our friends
hello he's not trying to convert me to
Islam I'm trying to convert him
Christian we're just two guys running
businesses and we like each other
oh by way he's a black guy on a white
guy just by the way ok you know I mean
why do we have to always be so dadgum
hateful I don't get it so I'm not mad at
you I'm opposite of you and if you don't
like that that just means you're
intolerant so here's the thing
let's first look at some data now if
Christians truly believe that poor
people exclusively are poor because
they're lazy they have a funny way of
showing it because of the amount of
money that is given to poor people
ABC News had this article out just a
little while back who is doing the
giving let's look at charitable giving
as the data because you wouldn't give to
something you don't believe in 3/4 of
American families donate to charity
eighteen hundred dollars each on average
of course if three-quarters give that
means one-quarter don't so we assume
that the rich give more than the middle
class the middle class more than the
poor I've heard liberals that care more
than less fortunate so we assume they
give more than the Conservatives do are
these assumptions truth or myth to test
what types of people give more twenty
twenty went on to to two very different
parts of the country with contrasting
populations Sioux Falls South Dakota in
San Francisco California the Salvation
Army set up buckets at the busiest
locations in each city Macy's in San
Francisco Walmart in Sioux Falls which
buckets collected more money Sioux Falls
is rural and religious half of the
population goes to church every week
people in San Francisco make much more
money or predominantly liberal and just
fourteen percent of people in San
Francisco attend church every week
liberals are said to care more about
helping the poor so did the people in
San Francisco who are wealthier and
liberal give more turns out the idea
that liberals give more is a myth of the
top 25 states where people give an
above-average percent of their income
twenty four of them were red states in
the last presidential election Arthur
Brooks the author of who really cares
says that when you look at the data it
turns out the Conservatives give 30
percent more and incidentally
conservative headed families make
slightly less on average and he says the
difference in giving goes beyond money
porting out that conservatives are 18
percent more likely to donate blood he
says this difference is not about
politics it's about a different way of
viewing the world and our view of
government so here's the deal if
Christians white Christians in
particular believe that the poor are
slackers overwhelmingly the number one
group that gives the poor are Christians
evangelical white Christians black
Christians Catholic Christians Hispanic
Christians are the number one giving
group in the United States and for that
matter worldwide of those who attend a
weekly worship service 91% give
something to someone 66 percent of
people
do not attend the weekly worship service
give something to someone a 30% drop off
by the way almost 25% drop off now I've
been in church for 35 years attended a
couple of different churches I met God
as an adult that Jesus is an adult the
churches I go to our suburban white
churches they're mixed they have some
rates some of every race in them but
they would legitimately be called white
evangelical churches not that somebody
was ruled out not that somebody was told
they couldn't come but it's the
demographic of the area the neighborhood
the preaching style all of that that
tends to cause that so there's always
some Hispanic folks and black folks and
whatever in there some white folk
there's a little bit all kind of folk in
theirs what amounts to but it's mainly
white admittedly for 35 years I do not
ever recall one single sermon in any of
the churches I've attended anywhere
where someone trashed the poor and said
you're poor because of a lack of effort
get up off your lazy butt however I will
tell you that almost every Sunday that
church is raising money to feed the
hungry in some city state or
neighborhood around us gathering up
clothes to give to people that are poor
building houses and buildings for people
that are poor in other countries and in
our own neighborhood we spent an awful
lot of time energy and money giving
money to the poor considering we think
they ought to get up off their lazy
butts according to this liberal
supposition it's just inconsistent it's
just actually not true and if you look
at it politically this comes out
conservatives give 30% more than
liberals several pieces of research show
that and in a bunch of articles on stuff
out there this this is in the New York
Times editorial are we cheap yes
Americans are cheap says the former
President Jimmy Carter recently said the
rich states don't give a damn about
people in poor countries and when it
comes to helping the needy in poor
countries YouTube singer Bono says it's
the crumbs
of our table that we offer these
countries crumbs because many other
countries such as Norway Portugal and
Japan give a larger share of their
wealth to needy countries the United
States gave 28 billion dollars in
foreign aid last year but as a
percentage of our wealth we ranked 20th
out of 22 major donor countries actress
Angelina Jolie is horrified by this it's
disgusting it's really disgusting she
said I think most American people you
know really do think we give more and I
know they would if they could understand
how little they give and how much more
we can afford to give absolutely without
even noticing it but wait a second when
you're talking about giving you can't
just talk about government giving see
Angelina Jolie would could look at
herself as an example of an a generous
American she gives her time her money to
charities around the world not counted
in those figures we were just talking
about and so do millions of other
Americans America is not just our
government it's 300 million individuals
and their contributions are far exceed
what the government gives America is
anything but cheap Americans give a lot
in last year they gave over 300 billion
dollars to charity so let's put that in
perspective and help you with this Bono
he's worried about Portugal and Norway
and Sweden we give the people of America
gave 300 billion to other countries to
help them as individuals last year which
is more than the entire national income
of Sweden I'll help you with your ratios
okay 50 percent volunteer their time
Americans are the most generous per
capita in the world the data says
President Carter is wrong if we look at
how much money Americans get per capita
compared to citizens in other country of
the world we find that the average of
American citizen gives away three and a
half times as much as the average French
citizen 7 times as much as the average
German citizen and 14 times more than
the average Italian citizen that's a per
capita number so the data shows that
Americans are generous that Christians
are generous and reaching out to help
poor people so why all the hate why are
we hating on the Christians who are
giving all this money to poor people
yes maybe it's all about dividing the
country for a because if you if you look
at the government and you think
government is the sole source of charity
then you would run an agenda with ran
articles like this that shows that we
need to give more to the government
because they're where charity comes from
and yet the data shows otherwise
so how do we help the poor what causes
for people to be poor I'll deal with
that one come back and then we'll take
some of your calls I want to know what
you think why you think poor people are
poor
[Music]
okay so we're actually using our brain
and not our emotions we're actually
thinking it's called critical thought
and we say a Washington Post article
comes out that says more than half of
Christians believe more than twice as
many Christians believe which the math
was wrong on by the way more than twice
as many Christians believe that effort
lack of effort on the part of the person
has causes their poverty more than
anything else
of course we've defeated that it's just
a liberal slant on something they're
just trying to stir it up we've defeated
it by understanding a that the data all
shows that Americans and conservatives
and Christians as three different groups
but also intermingled groups give more
by category than anyone else in the
world to the poor so why would you give
to the poor if you think they're lazy
and shiftless like that you wouldn't
you're trying to help them because we
that are in that category or in some of
those categories understand some things
so you just can't believe the liberal
Washington Post when they're trying to
say that white evangelicals that elected
Trump are primarily politically
conservative or greedy two-faced and
their motives can't be trusted that's
the essence of this it's hating it's
it's you know it's intolerance on the
part of the left so instead of dividing
this country between liberal and
conservative or black or white or
Christian and non-christian why don't we
just talk about the real problem which
is poor people how can we help them what
causes them to be there for real
well let me
it is not just lack of effort it's also
circumstances that they're born into and
it's also oppression from the outside
holding them there it's all three things
and it's all three things in different
ratios depending on the situation let me
give you a couple situations and we'll
look at the ratios for a second okay
let's take a person who is in Haiti been
through an earthquake has a corrupt
government poverty like no other on the
planet hardly Haiti so are they poor
because of a lack of effort you have to
universally say no their poverty is not
caused by lack of effort the islands a
pile of rocks to start with it's almost
impossible to grow something they're
drilling a well is a major undertaking
the banana republics that have been in
and out of there the corrupt governments
are just ridiculous and a lot of the
charity money that goes down there just
goes down a black hole sadly so those
people are not poor because they're
unwilling to work that is an absurd
statement
it's circumstances by and large and
oppression secondly in lack of effort
third but to a much lesser degree lack
of effort what everybody agree with that
say yes I mean so to my conservative
friends who say lack of effort is why
someone's poor you can hold the Haiti
example up and go well you're wrong it's
not the only reason people are poor in
that situation it illustrates the
circumstances sometimes another example
is I've got a friend of mine in college
he got a master's degree in accounting
and then he took up drinking ended up
homeless now I grew up white
middle-class like me went to the same
school I went to University of Tennessee
got a white middle-class education just
like me master's degree in accounting
shut up I mean that's a marketable skill
okay but not if you're in the bottle
ends up two broken marriages and
homeless so what's his poverty caused by
circumstances do maybe a little bit but
to a very very small degree agree was he
oppressed by someone did the man put him
down no not hardly not hardly
his choices are would put him down right
he's poor because of his choices he's
poor because of a lack of effort and
because he got addicted that's why he's
poor completely different than the
person Haiti agreed say yes everybody
really we understand how this works I
think about a buddy of mine good friend
I was talking to him the other day we
had a long discussion but this was kind
of fun before this article came out
oddly enough black guy african-american
guy whatever you wanna call him he calls
himself black so I'll call him black
that's okay
I'm not all worried about this these
labels you people are all get twisted up
about he's good friend of mine he grew
up in the hood and you know he told me
coming out of hood in America in North
America as a black guy he said it's
easier to get out of the hood then just
get the hood out of you
whoo he said you didn't have that
disadvantage and I said you're exactly
right I didn't we can label that white
privilege and try to call me a racist
but that wouldn't work because we've
already established I'm not shut up okay
so but it's easier to get out of the
hood than it is get the hood out of you
how many of you have experienced that
you when you had kids you opened your
mouth and your parents came out it's
easier to get out of there than it is to
get it out of you right and change is
hard for people so what's his deal I
mean is he successful he success you
know he had to overcome circumstances
some oppression because the racism is
still real out there and he had to make
good choices himself and he's by the way
ultra successful makes a lot of money
does very well really brilliant guy and
married up considerable by the way his
wife is brilliant too and so you know
I'm talking about
but he had to get the neighborhood out
of him and he had to get out of the
neighborhood circumstances and he fought
racism along the way he fought all three
I don't know if his equal parts but
maybe closer to equal parts in any of
the three we've talked about so far or
how about just poor white trash
Appalachia I was driving through
rural Tennessee this weekend drive by a
place it looked like if the porch fell
down and kill three dogs I mean you
might be a redneck if you know I mean
just trashy four cars sitting up on
blocks and the weeds coming around and
oh it's a little bit of circumstances
there you got to overcome a poverty
mentality you ever heard somebody from
your old neighborhood say the little man
can't get ahead you know what that is
that's a defeatist fatalistic attitude
that says that you don't control your
own destiny that somehow there's a
boogeyman out there controlling your
destiny you have to get the hood out of
you after you get out of the hood
white black Hispanic and circumstances
affect your mindset your belief system
therefore your ideas so it's more
complicated than just anybody can do it
it's more complicated than that and um
you know but truthfully in America in
North America you got a better shot than
anywhere else so this idea that the
government should take over because
other people don't love the poor is
ludicrous and it's sometimes loving
someone to say hey you're making
decisions that are keeping you poor
you're taking actions or lack of action
that's keeping you poor and sometimes
it's helping them get the hood out of
them as my friend who came from the hood
said so that's the deal so what we're
talking about here is healing the
brokenhearted I'm talking about
hopelessness and we're talking about
tools and belief systems so the danger
of something like this wopo article the
danger of the left wing nut job saying
that everything's fixed you can't get
ahead unless the government does it is
it's actually a Marxist agenda to march
towards communism because that's the
belief system that says the government
is the only thing that can fix things
that individuals can't fix themselves
now the truth is that individuals can
fix themselves with help in the
community that's the truth and the truth
is that circumstances can be shifted and
the truth is that money does those
things and sometimes there's a
government thing that works but you're
hard-pressed to find a government
program that's all poverty you've shown
me one anywhere a government program to
solve poverty it's just ludicrous it's
just almost impossible to find one so
that's what you're looking for so you
want to know how to help the poor you
got to work on all three of these things
and on different ratios for different
situations for poor people it's not
situational ethics or situational truth
it's that different people are poor for
different reasons primarily is it their
circumstances is it their decisions
beliefs effort or are they oppressed
oppressed would be like about the lotto
almost all lotto tickets are purchased
by poor people in four zip codes guess
whose kids go to school using the lotto
money white middle-class people that's a
government oppression of the poor how
about payday lenders are they oppressing
the poor yeah so do we need to stand up
against things like that because it
hurts the poor yeah we do we do we need
to give money and help the poor yeah we
do we need to call them out on their
decisions they're making sometimes you
bet we'll do all of the above around
here they don't make some of you
unbelievably uncomfortable and it's one
of my natural gifts back with your calls
on the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
so we're talking about this subject of
what causes property and I gave you my
opinion on what causes it I think it's
three things
biblically I think I can back that up
and it's not ever just one is my opinion
so I'm going to talk to you guys what do
you think Adrienne is with us in
Baltimore Maryland hi Adrian how are you
hi Dave it's good to talk to you you too
so tell me what your thoughts are on the
subject so uh my thoughts are I
completely agree with you that most of
the time they don't know that they have
better choices
I'm currently and helping teach a group
of homeless men who are actually coming
out of homelessness using your
principles and finding that they are
thriving we never knew that things could
be done differently they just didn't
understand that life could be done
different and I'd also like to say that
what put them in there will put them
there in the first place in your opinion
was it circumstances oppression or a
lack of effort on their part or a mix of
them in some mixer which was the major
one um I would say I'm a lack of
education for sure they had no role
models to show them how to do things
correctly for more than a technical
education you mean by role models you
mean belief that you know hard work does
pay off kind of thing yes oh these guys
work hard they work really hard what do
they believe but no huge okay go ahead
I'm sorry I'm sorry
most of them especially in the area I
live in I live in a pretty affluent area
most of them are just living too close
to the margin okay and I got clipped by
that all right how long you been doing
this I've been doing this two years I
also hope recovering at it cool how many
in your group currently I have a group
of three white men okay cool all right
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly send you
out books for all of them from me okay
oh thank you so much all right hey
thanks for calling in appreciate your
opinion Chris is with us in Los Angeles
hi Chris you're caught your question hey
days are you run comments on this I
guess is a proper word
ya can hear me fine yes sir oh cool
well it's pleasure to talk to you um I
guess I have an opinion on this where
you know I grew up in Long Beach
California my grandparents are from like
South Central Los Angeles and most of
the world knows it's not the most
affluent place in the world but my
grandfather was a landlord he came here
from New Orleans dhinam 1930s 40s had a
family here he you know created a he had
bought like apartment buildings and he
never really had anything growing up but
you know I grew up with my grandparents
so I learned from them so I guess from
my perspective it's more about
mentorships you know and it starts young
I think a lot of kids need to see people
who are actually doing it they need it
they need it you know get the influence
young someone to like teach them phone
to look up to you know they could tell
them you know is that a I'm trying to up
and put words in your mouth but I want
to make sure I'm grasping what you're
saying is that kind of a combination of
effort and changing circumstances that's
the mentorship right no it's both you
know it encompasses a lot of different
things because you need to be taught you
know a discipline of strong work ethic
young and it also you know you have to
do it ethically to I mean no one who
makes money unethically will last you
have you know if you're gonna have a
business that's going to last a long
time you have to make sure customers are
happy and you're taking care of people
and you were taught that from a young
age even though it was in a tougher part
of town oh absolutely I mean my
grandmother would take me to church you
know almost every day so I got it you
know so this is not even evangelical
thing this is just straight epics you
know like and work ethic and discipline
um but I you know I I went from you know
having no money at all to you know I'm a
millionaire now so I would say that you
know it's just discipline and I
encourage anyone you know who wants to
have a successful business to look
online because all you need is an
internet connection at a post office you
could ship products anywhere in the
world right man hey thanks for the call
interesting book input matt is with us
in New York Matt your comments on the
subject
Matt hey Dave can hear me yes sir okay
Dave up I just like to say I love the
show
I'm a student out here and basically I
think the main reason why there's so
many poor people in America is just
because they they're not educated on it
they don't have tools like that you
preach on this show and stuff like that
if you look at people we see people that
win the lottery all the time they go
broke because just by definition they're
not good with money you know what I mean
a lot of times they choose not to
embrace the market and are left without
many options as far as where to go and
how to get money several people have
said education and I wonder what they're
I mean I think you guys are all saying
the same thing I'm thinking when you're
saying that but I don't know if you are
something to ask to me education can be
just learning how to do something but
the kind of education I think we're
talking about in this setting is not
only how to do it but why to do it and
and the character around doing it I mean
you can know how to execute a task from
from going to a class agree but the way
you go about that is a reflection of
your character and I think that's woven
into this situation too hmm
is that what you're is that in there or
is that are you just saying our
education like going to class absolutely
so I recently graduated high school and
I'm a student in college right now and
basically in high school the things that
they're teaching as far as finances go
they don't really teach you that well
how to manage your finances when coming
to adulthood so I've had to go to
external resources such as your show and
other various websites and YouTube
videos to sort of teach myself how to
manage our finances and we're just not
teaching out in the schools in America
which is a really great tool that you
should use in building your wealth and
just furthering your a financial
knowledge gotcha
cool hey thanks for calling in man
appreciate your opinion so up next is
Randy in Cincinnati hey Randy how are
you doing well how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up so I had a
quick comment and question I'm new to
your whole program and my wife and I are
just getting started so um you know your
initial comment I agree with that the
article was very divisive but right
after you said
that you said a few comments like my
truck would eat your Prius and that you
walk around with holiday bullets and
don't you think that's a little bit
divisive in itself if you're trying to
have an open discussion you can
definitely thing to say well no it was
two things one it was to show the gun
comment was it to show a juxtaposition
that I can disagree with people who are
polar opposites and still be friends
with them and still help them the truck
comment was called humor I get that
specific I'm messing with your Andy come
on I kind of said but don't you think
that you just kind of have an open
discussion you're kind of like
alienating the Liberals if they want to
call in and give it a you point girl
yeah I don't really feel comfortable
calling Scottie you might have you might
make a comment like that you know they
might not that's true that that part
that that critique would be fair my
purpose was not to do that my purpose
was to say we help everybody and the guy
with a coexist sticker is polar opposite
of me I still help him he's still in my
classes she's still in my classes they
got great beard some of them in I mean
it's you know just laughing about skinny
jeans and all that stuff that's all just
cut not because I'm an old bald white
guy right you know so with no style with
no style sense whatsoever so you know
it's just a juxtaposition and it's just
like for some reason we've decided that
we pull up beside someone in traffic and
we hate them and we've never met them
basically based on their what they're
driving in their bumper sticker art and
I you know I get that all the time in
the seat that I sit in and I watch
people do it and it's like Pam you just
have to go about this for a political
agenda and you're right it's just kind
of sickening so if I if I if I got a
little bit off base I was trying to have
fun I'm part of and part of it I was
trying to show a juxtaposition if I
missed the mark I apologized all good
thank your time day Thank You Randy
appreciate you joining us it's a good
discussion Christians are more than
twice as likely to blame a person's
poverty on lack of efforts is the
Washington Post my contention is that
29% is not twice as over 46% is not
twice as likely it's not even half so
you're probably going to work on your
map number one my contention number two
is that that's not a Christian position
at all and the Washington Post
once again just like a lot of the other
news outlets on the left and on the
right are more about driving an agenda
than they are having a reasonable
discussion poverty is caused by
circumstances oppression from the
outside by government and marketplace
predators and by bad decisions
/ lack of effort it's caused by altering
things in different ratios in different
settings and we covered some examples of
that this our fun discussion I'm sure
it'll scare some of you folks up but
it's more the things I'm here for to
make you actually think instead of just
following along when you're head so far
up your politics you don't have an
original thought this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]